they were casting lord of the rings it
was some hobbit like character surely
that i didn't
grasp it i was looking for something
else and i remember seeing lord of the
rings in the theater with an
ex-girlfriend she turned to me and she
said you passed on a chance to be in it
i remember feeling so stupid
[Music]
the pianist
[Music]
that's luck where you know preparation
meets opportunity you know where i had
been yearning to find character with
that depth and a filmmaker with that
insight and he didn't fall into the
traps that many filmmakers fall into and
telling a story where you have to try
and you know it had a real slow burn
how
these atrocities
slowly became accepted in society and
how bigotry and hatred
can grab hold and how people can just
destroy evil and and horror within all
of that that is is incomprehensible and
and to play a very normal
person you know who's not particularly
heroic
he's dying
my child is dying of purse i beg you i
like you don't you have a drop of water
a man who
was slightly aloof and
would never imagine
witnessing all that stripped and losing
all that he lost
the responsibility that i felt in
carrying that role and and the process
and you know so deep so profound that it
it never left me and
aside from the obvious
career benefits and the accolades
it changed my life
as a man as a young man
i really
i feel like that movie made me
understand a lot made me realize
how much i'd taken for granted i want to
see her identity card what's happening
[Applause]
i
you know had to
lose a lot of weight so that there was
a transition from
spielman's
lowest
point after being in hiding and and not
eating
so you can't act
emaciated you have to become emaciated
and that was a technical process that
led to a discovery about
the hollowness and emptiness that one
feels when you are literally deprived of
sufficient nutrition then the physical
metamorphosis affects your
self-esteem and your energy levels and
your will power and your
strength i realize i've never really
been hungry
and uh it still breaks my heart how many
people are hungry in this world
and that most people don't understand um
we go to dinner
and there's all this food left over
it gets thrown out
massive homeless epidemic
children on the streets and so it's all
i mean it what it does is it gives you
a level of empathy
[Music]
and then i learned to play chopin i
don't know how to read piano but i put
my stuff in storage and moved out of my
apartment and i sold my car and i
disconnected my cell phone and i i did
all these crazy things to
have a sense of not knowing what i was
going to go home to and just purely
focus on that and then the music the
task of trying to
learn chopin
i found
such a wonderful distraction from the
hunger and then so i
found this new connection now to the
music this was a practical
task
to do the research to understand how to
portray this man and i find myself
becoming
somebody else
the darjeeling limited
let's give wes some love because wes is
the first director to embrace
some comedic sensibility within me and i
guess i didn't have a lot to show but
partially that is because you're not
given the opportunity to
show it so people are likely a very
serious actor and i'm like well let me
let me loose and then let's see if we
have some fun i love the way this
country smells i'll never forget it
it's kind of spicy that experience was
such a joy another life experience like
we lived in india together we all lived
in a house together
you know i'm an only child but i had
these
guys we were like brothers and i became
really close to owen and
jason is wonderful and i bought a royal
enfield and
ride around
india and
every day and nobody had a problem with
that it was just such a free experience
and we shot on a moving train we'd have
no makeup no
wardrobe process you had your
suit hung on your wall with the
microphone they combed our hair and that
was about it and then we'd have to get
on a train six in the morning 5 45
before it left the station because it
was on a route and we'd basically shoot
one way five hours or so and then shoot
on the way back he's got the code to his
ex-girlfriend's answering machine and
he's checking her messages
what when when did he confide that to
you
just now
why am i not a part of this wes is a
very
specific filmmaker you know but in that
film there was a looseness i guess india
inspired some of that in in all of us
and uh
and maybe within that story a bit more
of just giving in right uh
but um you know like the glasses were
obviously all part of the story and
structure and everything but i thought
it was hilarious that i i couldn't
really see through those glasses and so
every time i'd have to read i'd have to
take the glasses up and off and so it
became a whole thing and so now i
started doing that business and i i was
able to control it with my eyebrows so
that the glasses could fall when i'm on
command and
they became my father's glasses became
such a part of peter's character and
stuff like that like wes
indulged me and let me
play around with but so much is such a
vision what he wants and how we look how
we interact and timing and it was great
fun
great fun
grand budapest hotel i understood
wes
more
because we had developed a friendship at
that point jumping in and darjeeling i i
didn't really
know what i was getting into
and learned on the fly now i kind of had
a shorthand with wes and even more so
now i mean i kind of know what he's
looking for and i know what battles i
can't fight so i don't fight those
battles so i
can go right to what he likes because i
know what he likes
um and there's nothing wrong with that
this man is an intruder in my home it's
not yours yet dimitri only when probate
is granted and the deed of entitlement
you're not getting boy with apple you
goddamn little fruit
dimitri was such a
villain he was such a jerk
you know it was
fun to revel in being such a distinctly
bad character such a fun thing we shot
in
garlits in germany and we'd walk over
the border to poland and have a shot of
polish vodka and walk back and it was
like the whole thing was every every
experience with wes seems to feel a bit
wes anderson we all lived in this little
odd hotel that was lovely and you have
these communal dinners and he creates a
wonderful atmosphere and each time it's
just such a pleasure to meet all these
wonderful actors a writer or a friend of
somebody is coming to visit and they're
joining us for dinner he makes it like a
a troop and you're you're
you get to know each other and and
that's a wonderful thing
i'm going to blast your candy ass once
and for all right now
i think west just keeps honing in on it
on something that
no one
no one does quite as authentically and
and
it is it's him it's visible in every
frame
and that's remarkable that's like a
great artist when you say oh that's
that's a basquiat
[Music]
king kong i'll tell you a story i
haven't really
spoken about they were casting lord of
the rings
and
i somehow
didn't
grasp it don't remember what part i
would have been right for but it was
some hobbit like character surely that i
was looking for something else and
i remember
going to
see lord of the rings in the theater
with an ex-girlfriend she turned to me
and she said
you passed on
the lord of the rings i remember feeling
so stupid but i don't think i would have
gotten
the role of jack and peter's movie i
don't think that would have translated
and it was such a wonderful
thing i mean king kong is such an
amazing iconic story and peter told this
so well i mean with so much heart and
he's such a brave filmmaker
i guess i must have missed it
it's not about words
they wrote
that character which
in the original was much more of a
simple
ship's first mate he wasn't he didn't
have much and the dynamic was very
different and you know he created you
know he allowed nada not a
tough guy on a ship to go save the girl
and a guy who kind of
forced into being
present and having to
man up
and i thought it was wonderful
wonderful role wonderful process i
worked with andy circus and learned so
much about green screen and the
complexity of acting within that naomi
was wonderful in the movie and
to be friends with jack black and it was
some year because it was it was a nine
month shoot
and we had a hiatus
for three months or so where they built
kong stage where they had to finish
building the sets and an enormous
structure and in
that hiatus i had booked hollywood land
so i went with a few week break into
shooting hollywood land also abroad and
then had a couple weeks off and then
went back to filming that and i had
worked a year straight on those two
characters i don't think i'd ever done
that before and and um definitely not
done a few long films but uh nine months
is a
it's a lifetime as a character and
on location yeah i'm special and then
and then it was at the time it was i
think universal's biggest movie we had a
premiere on times square and they shut
down all of times square
the mayor was there
introduced us
to the city
and
you know this epic times square sequence
in the movie which by the way
i've done a fair share of driving in my
life and i had been boasting to peter
that i i can drive and i showed up one
day and he had
camera mounted here camera mounted here
on both sides of the car a rear-mounted
camera and one on the hood
and they had a race engine with a 30s
taxicab and he said you're driving today
and i did all that driving sequence i
came back and at one moment the door
flung open and i made a turn and the
door shut and there were
stunt men and extras fell down in my
path and i didn't kill anyone and we
were going down narrow
narrow alleys
with
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
cameras on the side and i didn't clip
them and i pulled back up and the whole
crew applauded me it was just like
it was it was the best day it was like
so fun and uh a lot of that is in the
movie it was a big deal i was on my my
face was immortalized on a mcdonald's
soda cup
i mean when does that happen
for anyone
and it's a it's a heartfelt movie i mean
it's it's very moving and
and tragic
[Music]
the village
the role was
written
someone with a more of a mental
disability a learning disability i did a
lot of research i spent time this lovely
woman who had a
facility in los angeles and took care of
these kids and
i did
acting workshops with them which was
amazing and what i understood and then
went back tonight with was that you know
children and
young adults who suffer from
some learning disability
are so sweet they haven't
become hardened like we have they don't
comprehend it enough it's just like
having a very rational discussion with a
child and
they grasp certain things but certain
things are just too far
beyond their ability to grasp
and their responses are
sometimes magical and
odd and
off but this character had a darkness
within him
and
so then i started exploring other mental
conditions that might disturb his
thoughts that process was really
interesting
um the character had a lot of levity i
like i liked that and i loved
experimenting what if we strike a deal
yeah capital idea it would be prudent to
keep our deal a secret can you do that
like a church mouse we lived in this
utopian society i liked the character i
really liked it i liked playing him
it was
it was light
even though he was screwed up i just it
was nice
it was liberating
peaky blinders i didn't really have a
desire to do much television to be
honest i love film
and
they started doing such good television
and it was harder and harder to find
really great independent movies because
they were doing fewer independent movies
and so the system
had changed it wasn't like i had sought
out i want to find a great television
project and uh stephen knight came to me
for that role which i'm i'm i really
appreciate because that's a character
you know
luca giangreta was like look at you
that's a character i've longed to play
someone with that kind of flavor they
don't make that many
movies like that either right i mean
other than scorsese that show is
something and it's it's got something
and so that was very exciting i could
have killed you when i walked through
the door
but you see
i want you to be the last
i want you to be alive
after your entire family is dead i had
to hold my own with great actors you
know killian murphy is just wonderful in
it and helen mccrory was just such a
remarkable actress tom hardy my first
scene was with tom hardy tom is just
fantastic and
beloved by the uk and the british crew
and shot on him and then i have to
i have to hold my own you know like okay
you were pretty good that was pretty
good i watch it okay let me my turn you
know it was so fun it was just so fun
and i got to you know just play around
with a genre that i
grew up loving and knowing and i could
be a little playful with it
and yet sinister and it's good
succession
succession is such a great show and
brian cox is great and
you know jesse armstrong and
these guys the guys who created this are
just it's so
diabolical and
funny and
all that's wrong what's going on in the
[ __ ] world it's like
they do it so well
and adam mckay and and you know they
just did great they they know how to do
it they know how to do it and uh they
were really welcoming to me that's that
you know to
to be
so hot
and so gracious they had written uh an
interesting role and then i
i said i had i
i loved the show it's my girlfriend's
favorite show i wat you know we love the
show and uh she's like whatever the role
is do it you know and i said i'll i want
to do it i'm not but i we we talked
through some
ideas about what i could be as this guy
and they came back with something that's
just
spectacular and they trusted me and i
trusted them and we
we showed up with something really fun
and i play a
powerful
guy who's
a big ego he puts them to the test a bit
and i feel like they're such sharks
they're such killers they're so you know
so to be able to get in there and play
jump in swimming with them and
bite back a little this is that's what i
live for
love the hard way it's one of my
favorite
films that i've done it is a role that i
really identified with a lot at that
time in my life it's a tragic
movie it's and the title says it all i
mean love is always difficult but this
guy had a lot of issues
and
was very smart
and
manipulative was a con man and a
hustler all of that was to defend
his own sensitivity
and like i said i that's not me but i
grew up around a lot of hustling
troublemakers and
i i had my share and
but i was cognizant of my empathy
and
sensitivity
within all the hardness and all
my boys and the [ __ ] that they get into
i always
felt for people in a way that was not
considered in a lot
when i was young
and i think he has a degree of that and
he doesn't show it he gets wrapped up
with this girl or rather she gets
wrapped up with him and and
you know he just destroys her um
and it's
it's really tragic um
but it's beautiful their connection and
he warns her to steer away and he has
this beautiful moment where he's like do
you like movies with the
happy endings or the sad ones
what kind of movies you prefer
the ones with the sad endings or the
happy ones
sad ones definitely
she says the sad ones
he says then you're with the right guy
and there are lessons within that and
she doesn't heed that
and uh you know it was just it was
special and marie noel who's his partner
wrote
the the film nailed it in in such a
interesting perspective it was a very
european film
about my city
and about everything that i knew and
graffiti and not that it was much it was
just like stylized and
yet
felt like new york
but with french cinema or something it
just was so
classy and unique and distinct
and
i had this python jacket and you know it
was a while it was so wild and it's
funny because you know i ended up the
pianist came just after that
and such a different
person and so much more an individual i
identified with at 26. the world really
was introduced to me as vladislav
spielman because of the success of that
film and it's a wonderful thing but it
was so strange because that seemed so
incongruous to people
and my love of hip-hop i almost scored
that film you know i had been sending
peter beats and
was doing all this kind of
asian
inspired things eastern
elements in it he ended up finding a
producer to do something
like that because i i ran off and
was in poland learning to play chopin
[Music]
summer of sam it was a real iconic new
york
film i love spike's work i think he's so
distinct and unique and has a point of
view and a vision and i was so excited
to get that role i knew very little
about
punk culture and that music scene i was
really into hip-hop and i was just like
that was so different from anything
that i knew other than in new york i
went to performing arts i had a lot of
friends who were you know i had a
diverse group of friends i hung out in
the east village a lot and i was living
in these villages when we made the movie
and but it wasn't my
wasn't my scene
walks in new york city
[Music]
from the ants to dwell here
[Music]
it was a really fun time because i
transformed quite a bit and would often
walk around i mean i did have a
bleach blonde mohawk at one point but i
had these liberty spikes and
wearing my chains and
and people treated me so differently
people literally crossed
moved away from that side of the street
and just kind of looked at me they
disapproved and i further identified
with the character and i further
understand that attitude it didn't occur
to me initially
how
judgmental people are based on
how you look as people
responded differently
i caught on to that and played with that
a bit more also like i learned to play
some of those tracks we did i performed
in cbgb i'm sticking cigarettes in the
fret and being spit on by
these
kids that they pulled off same marks and
you know i was spinning on them and it
was so raw and alive loud unencumbered
and i never performed
musically you know not that i was a
musician i thought i i
learned to play a bit i had a guitar all
the time with me i kind of got into it
you know and and embraced that you know
it's it was just really fun so i mean
there was of course the outsider
perspective
which i i would say is a through line in
many of the roles i played you know i i
gravitate to
representing the outsider not just
identifying and wanting to portray that
but representing
how we feel
as
individuals within society and where we
fit in and where we don't fit in and
the challenges of
not fitting in and being unique
you know rather than succumbing
the french dispatch i mean wes in the
french dispatch
has opened a portal
it's just
it's it's brilliant it's a whole new
level of wes
it's great i play an art dealer and i
have a love of art and i you know i'm a
painter and
you know benicio del toro is our
relationship is
so fun
it's so fun
and that segment of it of how wes
represents the art world and it's really
brilliant there's so many great actors
in this movie too i want to buy it it's
not for sale yes it is no it isn't yes
it is
yes it is there's just so many this is
so much to that movie like i i can't
even
get into it unfortunately he and i don't
work together but um tilda swinton's in
the movies she's amazing
bill murray it's amazing what west does
and all these characters are so so
unique each character is so unique
clean
that um movie is
you know something that i wrote
with my director uh paul salette it's
another side of what
our world is like today and it's a very
new york movie in its essence it's about
redemption and a man who's lived a kind
of dark past who's trying to do right
and do good and give back to society and
made some big mistakes in his life and
trying to make amends
and he's pushed to the limit but um
and then ultimately resorts to
what he understands and to to
kind of do right even though reacts
in violence now more than ever people
feel a sense of an awareness of a
helplessness and an isolation that
people have felt
we made this prior to the pandemic it
delves into
an opioid crisis conspired by and thrust
upon us by a handful of very powerful
people all the oppressive forces that
are so hard for young people to escape
live
full meaningful
lives without all that darkness and it's
an action thriller genre but i wanted to
create depth and
again a character that is deeply deeply
flawed not a good guy but i think it's
very representative of where we're at
it's something i've longed to do my
for over a decade you know i've really
wanted to write uh a movie
that
is tailored for
all these things that i know how to
convey and want to convey and then i
scored the film um which wasn't
something i had set out to do initially
but
ultimately it was making all these
tracks as i made the film and ended up
getting in an orchestra and having
french horns playing what i synthesized
and you know
orchestrating uh
amazing
piece of music
and doing all these original tracks just
to kind of tell this story so hopefully
that'll be the theater near you or
streaming near you or whatever happens
in this new world but uh it was exciting
fun to go down memory lane